okay this is gonna be a test because I
don't want to embarrass myself on a live
stream
let's do five plus three blitz or let's
find a game in the lobby oh man okay
all right goodbye world
I meant to play e4 oh my gosh wait let
me turn off their condition their London
system time Knight c3 g6 h5 does this
move I like my position Bishop e2 coming
oh no I can't move the Queen I can was
that Queen d2 Knight g4 Bishop g4
[Music]
every
why 4 minutes 44 seconds
black 4 minutes 37 seconds Bishop d7
ship d7 always play G for delay cob 96
c5 where's this Bishop on d7 hmm it's
plane 8g
ye v e5 while there's a III can't
complain some nice structure ideas of h4
h5
still has move upon time
so this pawn on e5 makes the Bishop on
g7 sad and d6 is a bit weak ideas of
rook t1 c6 it's play ch4
so my minor pieces Bishop on e3 knight
on c3 and night on e - black Bishop on
c6 Bishop on g7 9 on a6 structure is a3
b2 c2 e 4 f3 g 4h for black is a 7 b 7 d
6e v f7 g 6h 7 it's my queen on d2 don't
think i moved my queen yet made c7 - no
oh I didn't move my queen because I was
from earlier night to c7 let's play H 5
H 5 there we go and typing issues what
Vaughn Club kingi 7 what is this
King e7 each six
if Bishop f6 I played g5 in the bishop
stretch so he has to do that there's
ideas of Bishop g5 f6 just Castle
queenside let's play G fuzzy if F 5 I
take it if F takes G 5 I take it and I
can win this Queen Wow
let's play G takes f 5 or no G to G have
6
Queen takes f6
[Music]
maybe f4 supported by my Bishop Knight
and queen seems nice
want to open that file
Oh my rook can come to f1 in one move I
trade off my LightSquared bishop
white three minutes 38 seconds black two
minutes five seconds okay up about 90
seconds on the clock the e6 let's play
rook rook hf1
pressure that file
I'm threatening nasty things like f
takes e5 mainly it's hard to escape
because this major piece of this Queen
and King are aligned also some ideas are
five and could be nice
it's so dark in here g7 so I play f5 f5
takes takes his night moves and I win or
I play Bishop g5 this looks very nice
I better be seeing things correctly or
visualizing things correctly I find I'll
pre movie takes off 5 yeah I think
blacks in big trouble this King move was
a little bit too exotic Knight f4 so
let's play Knight
I should take that
so he has two bishops one on c61 and f/8
those king and queen are aligned
threatening Bishop g5 Brooks nicely
placed on f1 his rooks are not connected
it's hard to find a good place for the
King lacking is kind of stuck maybe King
g7 coming King g7 maybe f85 g7 so my
next one c3 c5 if I take
[Music]
re5 quintics are 566 so soon 95 point 95
attacking the b7 pawn G takes f 5 so
Queen B 7 or X queen bee queen queen b7
queen bee so what queen bee there we go
it's typing wrong
King e6 ah
that's illegal move and now mmm
where's my mate I could take on eight
because the bishop stolen f8 right
that's not Chuck right
can you seven Bishop takes age six he
takes age six check
I have takes e4 we take C Porsche
resigned
why this victorious yes I was beautiful
my opponent had no idea I was playing
blind folded I was beginning to lose
track but okay I know where my major
pieces are that's what matters all right
that was fun
hope the recording was okay I'm using a
green screen that's my first time using
the green screen I was cleaning the
closet and I randomly found the green
screen so that's right behind me but
people can't see it because that's the
point that's the point of a green screen
all right thanks guys for watching this
might go on YouTube so if it's on
YouTube I'll be back with more YouTube
videos very soon stay tuned goodbye